[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh Ed Reed Hall of Famer joining us on
behalf of Crown Royal we've got a
partnership there the former Raven
former defensive player of the year he's
also a Hall of Famer let's see how the
beard looks there Ed joins us now
how you doing I'm good man how's it
going do you want to hit anybody
um
no
did you but how do you how do you we had
Ross Tucker run played in the NFL he
said he missed the violence
you miss violence oh no
no
somebody's calling my phone uh oh
can you see me still yeah yeah I can see
you yeah you look good yeah so you don't
miss the violence do I miss the violence
no I don't I don't see a person
unless they locked up in prison
somewhere I was like you missed violence
yeah I'm locked up you know I can't wait
to get out
um but nah man I do not miss the
violence at all you know I'm actually
chief of staffer at the University of
Miami so I'm around it you know a good
bit I'm teaching it you know I'm letting
kids know that this is a violent sport
you know what I'm saying so now I don't
miss it man I I do miss you know the
times of of the the preparing for the
game and and and being with my teammates
and having them over to my house and
watching film and taking them out we go
and get dinner and stuff like that the
camaraderie part but
you know nah I don't I don't really miss
the the contact and all that like that
the position that you played and how
much has changed over the years being uh
you know free safety
it's changed a good bit
um it's changed a good bit football
hasn't changed but the rules and
everything has changed some things on
you know on how you can attack certain
things you know so it's always evolving
you got to be smart you know the first
thing I tell players about playing
football you got to be a smart player
you know you got to be able to adapt
football is life life is football in
life you gotta adopt football is the
same thing you know so
you know I was just talking about this
on how there's so many rude changes and
made you know players timid on what they
want to do or how they want to how they
want to play on the football field
you know but you're trained to be a
certain way in the off season you know
so you gotta you gotta better let it go
but I don't see that out there with many
players I see a little timid maybe maybe
the rules or something are holding them
back
you know it's definitely skewed towards
the offense because they want to produce
points you know fans like the excitement
of points and everything so it don't
seem like it works in the favor of the
defense it never did
if I put your Ravens defense out there
now
how impactful is that defense
very impactful very impactful you know
we we wasn't one of those defenses
you've seen that was um out there with
ill will just you know knocking helmets
off you know we hit people hard but we
wasn't doing it illegally
you know like you know you you my our
robbery team you know with other players
over there you know they had some dirty
players
you know over there and and that's how
they played the game you can see how
the the robbery between the Pittsburgh
Steelers
and the Cincinnati Bengals have picked
up on how both of those teams are
playing the dirtiest game you know I
don't think we've seen
that type of football
since the 70s or the early 80s where
teams are really taking shots at each
other but who was dirty that you played
against
who are you referring to
my robbery team I played for the
Baltimore Ravens yeah my robbery team
was black and gold you know I don't have
to point out specific players because
people should know you follow the game
you know I don't have to tell you Heinz
Ward was a day
that was a rule as a rule
like there's a rule yeah and I'm not
harping on it like I don't I'm not
bitter about it it's just it is what it
is like I never even though he was dirty
towards me I never went back at him as
much as I could have I never did
um why did he have it out for you
I mean it was they were they were they
Pittsburgh had that old school mentality
and they still do really in the center
in the Simplicity you know and I love it
man it's you know it's by any means
necessary you know
um but it shouldn't be at the expense of
taking the person out you know but they
wanted to win by any means necessary man
you know and if that's
taking the player out and him losing you
know his Consciousness or
you know maybe even missing the year
they they didn't seem like they cared
but if you see Heinz ward
I've told this to his face so he already
know but we've hashed that out man you
know I I
I got it out you know we talked about it
it is what it is you know Hans and I
shot a commercial get a road in the car
together man we talked about this like
you know he knows
yeah
um how would you game plan
for Lamar Jackson
how would I gain plan for Lamar Jackson
uh man I hope I would still be a raven
be on the same team
let's say you're on the Dolphins you're
on the Dolphins this weekend
I mean the Dolphins already played them
you know and they they game plan was
okay you know it's hard to game plan for
Lamar let me put you on the Patriots
since he plays the Patriots this weekend
it's hard man to game plan for a person
at that position that does the things
that he does
you gotta you gotta pick your poison you
know do you want him to run or do you
want him to throw the ball
you gotta you gotta pick one
oh I want him to pass
but but I think he's a lot better than
what people have given him credit for he
is that's all I'm saying you got to pick
your poison you know he he throw the
ball he can run the ball I would much
rather I would much rather have Lamar in
the pocket than have him running around
on us man I wouldn't want that because
he's showing you that he can score from
anywhere on the football field when he
runs that ball you know throwing the
ball has to deal with somebody else and
I can affect that somebody else that's
what I do I'm a secondary guy see I can
affect the receiver that has nothing to
do with Lamar you see what I'm saying so
if that if that receiver is not what
he's supposed to be then Lamar has to
run
you know so I wouldn't be that I would I
would I would definitely try to affect
the people around Lamar versus trying to
focus on the mark you know because he
gonna get his great players get this
who's the quarterback that was a half a
step ahead of you guys
thank you quarterback that was a half a
step of us
none of them
so Brady wasn't or Peyton wasn't done
nope
no
how about maybe a challenge maybe at
times maybe I had times on a plate
um you know maybe we had some games with
guys on the team with just not as good
to perform against Patriots or you know
Peyton you know but they were never
really that many steps ahead of us like
that you know except from a defensive
perspective we knew what they were going
to do we just might not had the athletes
too
playing against them
but Jeff did you have anything memorable
I know you had an interaction with Brady
uh oh yeah
one time you guys are cool
oh yeah I work with Brady I'm um I'm
with his company autograph with the nfts
and and trying to work out where he's
about to he's about to do a release in
the launching you know and um you know
that may be there might be a chance for
some people to hang out with Brady and I
maybe play some golfer do something
together you know yeah I like it making
peace with everybody
oh man we've been at peace man I I don't
I don't I don't travel off the football
field you know
worrying about a a player I played it
again so Feeling ill-willed by the
player you know Heinz was the only guy
who I truly was my Nemesis you know it
was like Batman and the Joker you know
what I'm saying but even even then once
it was over once the game was over man
you know it was over like I it was it's
a game like it's truly a game to me you
know and um I'm not taking and carrying
none of that stuff with me man about no
player now man you know I pray and hope
everybody was healthy and and and get
what they deserve out of the game but no
I'm always fascinated when I talk to
guys who played a violent sport like
Troy Polamalu when you hear that voice
I'm not scared of Troy Polamalu but then
I see him on the football field and I'm
scared of Troy Polamalu those guys who
sound a different way just like you I
mean you're chill get on the football
field now you're different
yeah it's different man it's no
different than you've been in your demon
your domain right now you know where
you're at right now that's where you're
comfortable that should escape from
everything you know you're a totally
different person in this like you know
I'm saying that's that's what you're
most comfortable you know and um you
know when you get public and all that
you know you handle yourself accordingly
you know
you know I'm pretty sure it's different
you know for you when you're when you're
in public you know you're probably more
chill and you know or are you probably
still talking a lot I'm just like I am
this way I'm 24 24 7 just like this yeah
but football is different man because
because you know
it's a it's a true warrior that you have
to put on to play especially at the high
level that me and Troy played on it's a
true warrior that you put on and when
you go
and when you enter the stadium man you
know like it's a totally different
mentality you know what I'm saying and
that mentality is not for the real world
you know just walking around
you imagine me walking in the grocery
store and hitting somebody you know or
swiping swiping some milk out of their
hand that they picking up and I'm like
no dairy products
you would go Matumbo on them you know
I'm like defending in the grocery store
or in the parking lot or something man
no man why just dude like that all the
time uh we're talking to Ed Reed he's
partnering with uh ubereats Crown Royal
kicking off year two the uh whiskey
sponsor of the NFL what are you doing
with Crown Royal
man I've teamed up with Crown Royal
um we've we've teamed up over the years
it's been a long time partner at this
point and we teamed up with Uber Eats to
you know
give back to the hospitality industry
you know obviously the military and all
the things that they do blessing to all
the military people out there
um but just want to get back to those
those people man who are doing those
things the small things you know that
people tend to overlook you know the
Uber Eats while you're at home with your
family and friends enjoying the game
enjoying your Crown Royal
drinking water you know you could order
Uber Eats and they show up right at your
door you know and that's huge man you
know that's huge so
crown and I want to give back to those
Industries you know uh Carl's been doing
it for some time now
you know and and giving away a lot of
money man you know and and but but just
this space right here is what we talk
about just giving back to them and
paying homage to them great to talk to
you again how's the hair looking how's
the hair it's the same thing
looking good looking good thank you
great to talk
it looks like the bus did you did you
think about changing it on with your
Hall of Fame bust with your hair
not at all
um not at all man I could show you a
picture of me I think I'm like six or
seven years old I got to throw you know
like it's always been a part of me man
you know it's always been a part it's
always been there
you know so
it's what I'm comfortable with you know
no matter what people say no matter what
people think you know
YouTube man women out there kids man be
who you are you know what makes you
happy and you go from there
good to talk to you again
maybe we'll cross paths here soon thank
you Ed
thank you man I appreciate it man you
gotta you got a whole bunch of stuff
right here I know I know I got I got a
bunch of stuff here I got the ultimate
man cave I got all kinds of jerseys in
here I got uh helmets you got some
military stuff yeah some loads of
microphones another microphone that's a
gold ball
gold bar oh yeah it's a gold football
there I got uh Tiger Woods golf ball up
there I got Shacks Shaq shoes down there
Tim Tim Duncan from the NBA Finals 1909
I got a bunch of stuff in here it got a
bunch of stuff awesome yeah that's
awesome okay uh that's what you mean to
the kids you got some pinball machines
in here yeah let's go got a pinball back
there you know I feel like you might
have I feel like you might have an
electric football game somewhere then uh
we might have that
I mean I don't know why I don't have
something for the greatest safety of all
time in NFL history in here no but I'm
thinking about bobblehead or something
right there yeah bobble head with uh
your big fro I like that uh hey uh good
luck to you great to talk to you again
as always appreciate it Dan be blessed
thank you that's Ed Reed take a break
back after this